jenna freeman is truly
i'm not gonna say this because it's
gonna sound like i'm being dramatic i
was gonna say my favorite comedian
performing today but everyone's gonna
think that that is i'm being hyperbolic
you are it is a maybe but there's
different kinds of comedians and you are
easily
in my top like three favorite
like to if i see you on stage somewhere
i like run out to see what you are doing
right or like i am it's very hard for me
to hear comedy where i don't know where
it's going not because i'm like so great
it's just when you've been doing it long
enough or you know the comedian you know
where they're going to go like it is
you you are the most surprising comedian
to me and the bravest as someone that
feels like i kind of don't people like
she doesn't give a fuck like about me
like i look at you and i'm like
she does not give a fuck like you to me
are the most fearless comedian on stage
offstage you're the most scared i've
ever i'm really scared and i think that
my stand up right now is you know i i'm
building but it's like you know but i
appreciate that you're one of the
bravest communities i've ever seen i
would never accept a gift from a fan
well okay so just out of the box there
are like three moments like what's in
the box does it sound like a ticking or
is it just gonna be like a
jenna was uh with us in seattle this
weekend on tour i'm taking my shoes off
you can't see and you shouldn't see
because i i'm gonna get if you're gonna
show my feet i'm gonna get paid for it
by the way if you're not but if you show
your feet men might not want to murder
you anymore because if women have ugly
feet they won't come anywhere near you i
have a five on wiki feet i think i i
think that's the only thing so i've been
doing comedy for 15 years and the one
thing that's like taken off without any
effort has been my feet
like i
i have like an eight or nine on what
maybe an eight now i don't know maybe i
have some haters but yeah
people love i don't know it's the only
thing i've nev like it's because like
when josh and i were first dating he was
like you know you're on wikifeed i'm
like why are you on it
he's like i googled you and i was like
the first thing that came up it's like
i've done like stuff at the daily show
and blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah emily
is awesome
it's hard to just like do things and
it's like your feet people really like
your feet here's what i'll say
uh
uh i was looking at your hands on the
plane when you were talking and i was
hypnotized you have the most delicate
hands
unless you want to kill her in which
case her hands are very strong and burly
and i wouldn't fuck with her but they
are so beautiful
here you can see them
okay now that we'll clip that out for
only fans um okay so we're gonna jump
around but we did get to spend time
together this weekend which was kind of
exciting because usually the first thing
i ask people on the podcast is are we
friends and then the guest has to answer
yeah and i think i'm really bad at
faking it but i really had a nice time
with you this weekend i saw a side of
you i hadn't seen and i just i i'm a fan
and i admire you and you're cool and and
i just you know so i'm not faking it but
if we hadn't hung out i'd probably be
here just like this would be so awkward
i'm glad we did i'm glad we did it yeah
and i'm also glad that i saw you like
the toll that what you do takes on your
personal life i'm not happy about it but
i binged indefensible which is on amazon
how would you describe this show just
before we get into uh there's a lot of
murder talk today a lot of women that
are murdered and then the people that
got away with it and the defenses that
they use murder podcasts are everybody's
favorite i have played your uh conan set
before the one where you talk about all
the murder podcasts we will put it in
here
play the news is pretty depressing
lately
so to lighten the mood i've started
watching true crime
i feel bad for the amount of true crime
that i consume but to be fair women we
don't watch true crime technically we
study it to make sure
to make sure we don't end up on it
and true crime is kind of feminist it's
the only time the entertainment industry
will take a chance on an unknown female
lead
i've played on the podcast before i
think it's one of the best late night
sets ever done what american cunt uh
which was your album from 2016 or your
special from 2016. uh she calls
abortions a bobo in it if anyone wants
in a bobo i mean there's shit in it that
makes me just laugh so hard we'll talk
more about it and uh and the list goes
on and on um
but indefensible as soon as i see that
you're doing something i get so fucking
excited because i would say the thing
that i have shared the most from like
youtube clips is the series you did the
ted bundy spoof uh the new york times
thing oh thank you so much ben cronberg
two was in that and the this guy keola
rosella who's
dramatic directing but he directed it
can you just say what it is and you got
a season desist from them right so um
there were
in like two around 2009 there were these
do i look at you or do i look wherever
you want
oh my god you're just now you're just uh
see people are going to stalk you after
this because what you're doing is so
endearing
it's so cute i'm falling in love with
you
you're not no one's going to kill you
now that you're getting famous that
makes you the safest uh you talk about
kill everyone yeah but not this many
famous people talking about me we were
talking about you doing the ted bundy
i would say one of my biggest
fascinations in life and i think this is
the first time we started texting i
reached out to you after watching this
this series you made on youtube
and it uh ted bundy is there's a huge
fascination with ted bundy he's hot he's
handsome
like
zac efron's playing and we're doing a
new ted bunny movie every year like it's
wild like um and the ted bundy tapes we
want to listen to him like we just love
that we love this guy his cue rating is
through the roof he's just lovable
he had he had a cast in his trunk like
it's like it was just
he thought it through i think we
actually live like back here where i
live is kind of where i can't believe
you stay where you live well we're gonna
have to take that out okay like as okay
as if every uber driver and
uber eats and ease weed person doesn't
know that i live here's an alien if i
have nothing this is going to be in like
the montage of like your like netflix
documentary murder
honestly she loved to be open
if it hasn't happened by now it's not
going to happen and also i had all these
we are aging out of the murder ability
yeah all that like all the um i know i'm
at the point where there's no point in
killing me because they come i'd be like
fucking do it let's go there's like
like there's a murderer like a one we
wanna you know we're gonna go for it i'm
like
and also i feel like number one i have
many many pitbulls but number two i have
a robot that looks exactly like me so i
feel like i'd be such a stupid person to
kill okay i'll quickly talk about you
the new york times with so many murder
stories that just fyi
i'm gonna try to be gentle on the murder
jokes oh it's fine but the the new york
times video that uh we made um i had
seen a bunch of actual new york times
wedding videos and there was this one
that i can show you i'm blank in the
name of it now jen and alex or something
maybe and the guy seemed i'm i should
follow up that was a decade ago and see
what they're about because like there
was like an awkward energy where was
like that guy seems there's something
going on
they would like they did like these i'll
so that i saw that video and it made me
giggle and then i was like oh we should
do a parody of this but just the guy is
like a total serial killer so it's like
ben croneberg super funny comic
definitely hilarious hilarious not ten
bunny he looks like ted kaczynski he's
like got like a serial killer which
one's ted kaczynski una bomber oh got it
um but ben cronenberg is this comic he
just had that vibe we shot this thing
this guy kaiola russella directed it and
it was so close to the actual like
template and like the style and
everything we use the new york times
logo
and we just put it online and it was
like 2009 when you could put something
on youtube we put like new york times
dash weddings vows ted and gracie where
now the term would be an easter egg but
people thought it was real because it
was like
it showed up with all the other weddings
yeah yeah it's like binging on new york
times wedding videos no one's going to
show up dude and i don't mean interrupt
but just so the people listen you know
that like like
where what i gleaned from it like i
always thought because ted bundy had a
girlfriend that he didn't kill when i
was single forever i was like why
how can ted bundy have like a healthy
relationship and i can't
that was like i that was my thing okay
so these ted bunny
these videos and like the the your
character does not know he's a serial
killer but the audience does and it is
so
fucking fun to watch yeah it was fun to
play it was like fun to do that i
i remember calling my dad um who works
in medicine about um
there was like a line at the end of the
first one where like about decomposing
fingers and like i don't even know what
it was but it was like so fun to like
collab with my dad there's a line about
like what happens to swollen extremities
yeah and that like my dad like gave me
that line hold on there's a thing
do you know about
um i did a thing the other day with uh
katya um
from drag race and there's a thing now
where it's not a real thing it's from
like urban dictionary it's called uh
when you
jump on a
bloated corpse
it's like a
and the sexy body
makes you high because there's some
chemical in a bit like ether or like i
don't know it's like something like that
and and you inhale the fumes there's a
mortician thing that they do possibly
get high yeah i think so
can we make a pilot for cvs
[Laughter]
uh mung diving
is when your friend go through the
obituaries find a recently dead ant uh
person go to the graveyard lay next to
gravestone then you and your friend flip
the loser has to put his or her mouth on
the dead girls uh well this is getting
very specific okay let me that's urban
dictionary i'm skipping some things okay
let me it's really just about friendship
when two people take a corpse into the
desert leave it there for two or three
days till it gets juicy the people see
they don't get juicy it gets juicy after
the person a puts their mouth on the
asshole the corpse ball person b jumps
on the stomach of the body this causes
the intestinal tract to shoot into the
other person's mouth this is not what i
was looking for but i know what we're
pitching for uh
our next quibby show
but and then munging is when you inhale
mung is
where did you find that text wait
monkey
monkey is oh when you suck the juices
out of a corpse
the only thing about it that's funny and
it's so like profane with like this true
crime show that i'm doing i'm trying to
be taken seriously
it's like hard enough for women
by the way and by the way no since i did
five minutes and she's crying already
you guys women are emotional you can't
hire them they just like start crying
media trained
[Laughter]
okay i'm just trying to get people to
like take like violence against women
can you please stop crying well who's
gonna i mean i don't know what to tell
you it's just like we can't even get
through this
gosh
okay here's the thing though here's what
i'll say
you i've been nominated for an oscar did
i make that up
that's not true no i have yeah i'm just
crying so if no one takes you seriously
that's on you that everyone takes you
seriously
everyone takes you seriously you're like
the only person i respect sorry i'll
stop talking about
shit but you know what a human centipede
is yeah of course okay good um
indefensible i think is easily easily
one of the best made shows i've seen
that's really nice of you to say and i
don't and i just wouldn't say anything
otherwise because the way that it is
edited the way that there's like like
the it's such a journey because you're
you're you're um talking about all these
murders in a way that is like
you know it's i'm not shutting down and
going numb and disassociating which a
lot of times like hearing just murder
the woman was like you do it in this way
that is like just impish enough and like
playful enough thank you to where you're
like
uh poking fun at really horrendous
things in ways that i can actually
process it i tried so hard i didn't know
if we'd be able to make that show and
amc reached out to me i'm kind of
shocked i'm shocked i i didn't i didn't
pitch that show because i was like no
one's gonna like this is not something
that i would ever be able to sell
but they they saw the conan set they
were like building their true crime
franchise they reached out to me they're
like do you think we can make like a
kind of comedic show like this and i was
like i really don't think so
and then i don't know if it's possible
and then code would happen and i'm like
anything's possible yeah so
um the first episode which was a pilot
we shot
i was rusty on my interviews but the
story was insane and we actually got
access to a guy who's still alive who's
an expert witness who's
he's um been called into court um on
behalf of defense teams and he said
really fucked up shit um and people
believed it like this woman wanted to
die and she provoked her husband this is
a woman that was murdered by her husband
is this the one where they all said she
was a nag this is yes this is alana
steinberg uh scottsdale arizona 1981 she
was murdered by her husband she was
killed by her husband stephen who
stabbed her 26 times in her sleep um and
he got away with it
uh part of the reason was because his
defense team
um built up this like naggy jap
stereotype like she drove him to kill
her and so he had like a dissociative
episode from her nagging and spending
and spending even though it was her
family's money oh that's a whole
separate and there was so much also the
show was supposed to be an hour i just
given her timeline and everything i was
like i really want this to be a half an
hour because part of my problem with
true crime is that it's like so
gratuitous and long yeah and i was like
i don't want to put in any detail i
don't want to do any red herrings i
don't want to do any details i don't
want to i don't want to do like the
nixium documentary when it's like 12
parts to say one really quick story
about the guy who played well no that
was just a show about volleyball
that became a sports show halfway i know
it was a volleyball what will happen
when you've got like a long pigtail
least attractive and least charismatic
guy still ended up with a cult since
you're an expert on murder
um expert on all things murder i have a
couple hot takes and i would like to
know what you think of the staircase the
staircase is easily my favorite
like
true crime documentary it was made on
sundance a very long time ago and then
kind of brought back of the uh
woman that was found on the bottom of
the stairs so i that's interesting
because that's like the only so if you
guys have not seen it we're about to
spoil it it's been 15 years well that's
the one that so i i've watched a ton of
stuff i watched like a ton of stuff and
that's the one that i had never seen and
then i went back to watch it and i was
just kind of like i kind of
couldn't get into it wow that's wild
because i don't think he did it
okay and i'm very
i'm not gonna fight you i think it's
because well because it's the kind of
thing where i do feel like that one is
so ambiguous to me
or like another wife who fell down the
stairs one wife fall down the stairs and
then they find out like five years later
another woman has fallen down the stairs
and then there was like a hawk theory
there was an owl theory which is the
only thing that explains the conclusions
on her head truly the only one so i
don't know if this motherfucker's
training owls to knock her down the
stairs that could be the case for all i
know but like it was almost just going
through it it was the first time that i
was like oh my gosh juries are not a
good this is our system's a little
messed up yeah like this is the kind of
witnesses they're able to get up here
should be vetted by some other
organization and
how homophobic they just turned it into
yesterday and they found out later who's
gay but just because you're gay doesn't
mean you're a murderer you know what i
mean so then it was like all
it became all about him being gay so gay
just equaled guilty
and then just like a series of like i
think he's a he's a malignant narcissist
but i also was like why would he allow
these cameras in his house all day every
day if he was guilty guilty and because
that's the kind of thing that you're
like either you do that if you are like
you have lied to yourself about it yeah
and you think you're innocent or you are
innocent yeah that's interesting i so i
didn't i don't know all the details on
that but i do think to your point about
juries i think none of us think about
the criminal justice system until we're
in it yep and we think that it's like
fairer than it is
and then when you're in it when you see
how the sausage is made like the one
thing i learned from doing this show is
just the theatrics yep which i didn't
realize like defense attorneys are
really good actors like and it's what
they wear and how they act they use
props they'll bring props into a
courtroom this one guy we were talking
to that's why we love legal shows it's
like we they're all like rob lowe
you know what i mean yeah they're all
like so smooth and so like such good
orators
it's just like i just didn't realize
like um
you know this one guy was like yeah we
use cartoons for juries and like did
they get snack time like yeah yeah yeah
you get naps yeah it's like they're just
like 12 or in some cases six people yeah
decide someone's fate i mean this system
is is really really flawed and you know
um it's about charisma and it's about
certainly and who has the money for the
good defense and like all people's
biases and on the jury you know like
that's why it's so hard to prosecute sex
crimes because like women start from
like a default like people if as a
society we don't believe women
then when their murderer you know like
that it's just harder for them to get
justice and then so just in general like
the history of
men murdering women like that's sort of
a big part of this and then i was really
finale the women are the killers
the last episode the women are there yes
yes i love which i love so which i loved
i love uh i love uh thelma and louise
helen and all girls hell is that footage
of them in the fucking
uh she's like you shall not only
literally they couldn't prove that they
were uh guilty so they put these two
like fucking they can't stop yapping
like we'll just put them in a room and
run a camera and sure enough they just
like did it
and uh and but also like all these
defenses were so fascinating to me like
the gay panic defense the panic defense
in general like if someone freaks you
out and you kill them
it
might not be a murderer it might be you
killed them and murder and you killing
someone are different things there are
like different degrees of murder like in
the way that inuits have like many names
for snow in america we have like many
names for murder
and so you've got like first degree
second degree like manslaughter like
involuntary voluntary la la you know yes
and uh is it different state by state
yeah laws are different state by state i
think like we're more interested in it
now because i like the george floyd case
because of kyle rittenhouse we're like
we're all kind of like learning like how
the system works and i think like in a
lot of cases you'll have like in the gay
panic episode
there were only like two options it's
like first degree murder which is really
really hard to prove that somebody like
intended to kill and then there was no
manslaughter or second degree so then it
was like either he's he definitely
intended to do it or he's innocent so by
the way can i just say really quick
because this i had i i did not know
about this story it was a jerry springer
episode
where a guy was meeting his secret
admirer and walked on stage and then
jones jenny jones jenny jones and the
secret admirer was a man
that like gave him a big hug
in a very feminine way and then you see
him sit down and like rage comes over
his face and then he killed the guy like
scott amador was a victim because he was
embarrassed on national television and
the case was basically you humiliated me
and then yeah so his attorney used gay
panic he got 15 years and now he's free
got it but he was like he might listen
to this you were gay
so hey fuck face
face he got 15 years so i think what
happens is with the game you have no
female admirers because you're fucking
ugly and short
why no one she's only speaking for
herself sir
dude come over bitch so
i know what you're probably thinking
these two women
should be murdered
for two women that are really
mad at murderers
most are women
we're very anti-murder
unless
we're talking about these two women
um
two women that just talk about how much
therapy they have we're going yeah sure
you sure we don't need to upgrade
therapists
uh
it is no surprise that this podcast is
brought to you by better health i love
better health sometimes that was text
better help and i'd be like you up i'm
sad
you know i ever do that and they get
right back to you yeah because better
help will assess you and your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist i like to order a
pizza and then see if i can get my
better health session before it's
delivered so i call real quick and i'm
like hey i'm fat but i got the food i
want to eat it hey i'm about to do
something that's calling a suicide
hotline i'm going to binge
it's all the way it's all the way you
better stop they're trying to talk me
out of it when they get there i'm like
you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna donate
this pizza
what you need to do instead of call you
need to call better help and then you
need to call a professional hacker to
hack your phone and cancel the live
right and in addition to all these
wonderful things better help is more
affordable than traditional offline
therapy and financial aid is available
so you have more money for pizza it's
more affordable than a pizza that's for
sure betterhelp wants you to start
living a happier life today it's a
personal trainer for your brain
special offer for good for you listeners
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com whitney the key to
therapy is like it needs to be a daily
ritual yeah you know
therapy is a weekly thing but it also
needs to be a daily ritual therapy
doesn't only happen when you're in the
office it's the daily
things the habits that we build you know
wake up look in the mirror smile for 10
minutes make it a habit to take care of
yourself habits and rituals or synonyms
in addition to taking care of your brain
you got to take care of the container
that drags your brain around and you
need to be aware of what you're putting
in your body every hole
you need to be aware
some of them don't call you back gaps in
your body should be filled and gaps in
your diet shouldn't be ignored
over 97
of women aged 19 to 50
are not getting enough vitamin d
start a new ritual learn how to swallow
some vitamins and shakes also yeah
exactly sorry um as someone with double
d's i know a little something about d 95
of those people are also not getting
their recommended daily intake of key
omegas omega-3s there's no sex joke
there it's threesomes
rituals essential for women 18 and plus
grace get out of here multivitamin was
formulated by exhaustive research to
help fill nutrient gaps in the diets of
women 18 plus grace get out of here it
works so well we won't let grace have
any
it is formulated with nutrients to help
support brain health bone health blood
health and provide antioxidant support
take it but don't let your enemies take
it
right now ritual rituals offering our
listeners 10 off your first three months
visit ritual.com whitney and turn
healthy habits into a ritual that's 10
percent off at ritual.com
whitney i really
don't i'm not scared of men anymore i
don't know i just can't i don't have the
bandwidth yeah good yeah
i don't what it is is men the kind of
man that wants to kill me is also
also so
um probably disgusted by me that i feel
like if they showed up and i was like
hey what are you doing they were just
like oh never liked so shrill i would
just like they wouldn't be able to go
through with it
yeah because they'd have to like hang
out with me because i'm it would take a
while i can't i don't know my entire
chest is made of silicone like i'm
basically wearing a bulletproof vest at
all times
i just um
okay you're so bummed
i'm not bummed i'm like i you know i
think i do think i've always felt that
talking about the things we're afraid of
i don't think the person it makes me
less fearful i don't think that the
person that
killed someone after jenny jones in a
gay panic first of all knows who i am
they're not female comedy fans like they
don't know i know they like appreciated
just gonna stay out of this but we know
whose podcast they listen to and i don't
think it's mine like i don't think those
people even think i exit no i exist
okay you know what i mean sure like if
the guy that like killed a guy off to
jenny jones no i get it yeah i mean
podcasts it's not it's like okay i get
it yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like who is
it like alex jones or i don't know he's
not i'm not in his algorithm yeah no no
i hear you but so the whole thing with
like you know those defenses and i my
two favorite episodes are the one about
the rough sex offense consent offense
and the one about the gay panic because
those defenses
rough sex defense or the consent defense
has been outlawed in the uk we could
actually generate political will to get
it out loud here to like raise awareness
and actually do something so that like
people who kill people during sex which
isn't a thing that
nobody can sense to die is the whole
point like the rough sex defense is
bogus because when you strangle someone
it takes a really long time and that's
not enough that's correct yeah but but
like those defenses shouldn't be allowed
in the courtroom and so like if people
more people knew about that there's like
a level of like advocacy which i know
sounds unfunny but for and then the gay
parent defense is now outlawed in like
15 states sure so it's just about like
getting people aware of these things
because it's fascinating to me that gay
panic is a defense
like a trans panic i was going to say
transpanic is a big one and then also
because man but like like just a man
coming at me that's not straight
straight i had a straight panic because
a man was coming at me and like trying
to uh yeah yeah yeah yeah kill me
like yeah well they're like shades of
self-defense so like these defenses
aren't necessarily used to like get
somebody off for the most part but it'll
like reduce their sentence i do want to
talk about this though and i floated
this by you on the flight yesterday
because i'm embarrassed to bring it up
but i also don't care and i'm gonna have
some tunes trying to get through it so
as someone i don't talk about this a lot
but um june shine ituneshine please help
me with my plan b
okay so as someone that is as i get
older maybe as i get
more thought of as someone that's in a
power position i don't know when i was
in my 20s the only kind of sex i wanted
was like i wanted to be enveloped by a
man and like have like hot cocoa and
like sex like with my jammies on and
like just the most like hair down
home
with eight candles dripping on me um and
as i get older i don't know maybe it's
like having watched porn which i didn't
do until much later tumblr used to have
uh
like really cute porn that like looked
consensual it was like real couples and
it was like yeah they gotta be concerned
it was like on a loop
like it only went it was like oh it was
like the first giphy's it was like
they'd go like 30 seconds and so that
you're not like having to like see like
bruises or like like crazy shit in the
background um and uh
and then i don't know i'm just at a
point where i'm very rough i think i'm
into very dominant sex now
and
i want the murderers listening to know
that no i'm just saying like there is
you know and i was just watching this
episode of mad men actually last night
that was all about uh when those nurses
were killed and the the episode where
all the men were kind of like oh women
love to be
hurt basically they want it they're into
it like there's an episode sort of about
that it was very deftly done and i
believe this should be okay
wanting to have rough sex yes and it is
okay i believe no one's saying no rough
sex yeah just like people all they're
saying is people don't consent to die of
course of course but i'm just saying i
think that there's also just in this
area of talking about murder and stuff
my own brain i just want to if you choke
someone out during sex they're most
likely not going to die because it takes
like a really i talk to a medical
examiner well men can can't really do it
anyway but it takes a really long time
to kill someone via strangulation yes so
somebody dies that's not consensual at
all it was never
but um i did by the way guys don't know
how to do it anyway but most like during
sex i don't think a guy has successfully
done it in my experience except i did
date a doctor uh recently who
he
he i basically kind of had to request it
because he was younger and like younger
guys are terrified to do anything and he
did it like this
he
took his fingers and like put it tightly
around this part of my neck and i was
like well that actually
it's like the first time i've ever been
weirded out and like sexually active
because like he did it like properly
straight instead of like around the neck
you know but i just i don't know
it's something that i find myself
grappling with you know as someone that
like constantly in the back of my mind
is like are you a bad woman or you're
like just i think that people like what
they like and we shouldn't be able to be
ashamed of it if i want to wear heels
one day and sneakers another day and
make up one day and if i want to be
i know so many women right now they're
like do i have to like be a billionaire
can i just cut do i have to hustle all
day i don't know any women
that think they're like i don't wanna i
don't want money
i know but like i just wanna be a slave
to
am i allowed to like have a lingerie
store
where i sell
do i am i the person who's who's like
determining i'm just saying i feel like
there's a lot of like feminist bullying
where women can't do i think you should
be able to whatever you're doing as long
as you want to do it i think there are
male comics with podcasts who think that
there's feminists in fighting and
bullying but in reality it's not we do
get along yeah we're communicating you
guys think we're at each other's throats
because you guys like it's like you guys
like made that up like i really do feel
like it's like i don't want to blame
individual men but i do think it's like
this like
one at a time woman thing that makes
women be catty and infighting is like
this artificial thing i think women
really are like for the most part and i
don't want to speak in like absolutes
but like helpful communicative friendly
supportive and when we're not it's
really just like our own internalized
misogyny yeah and some aren't and like
that's awesome that's true
and whether it's because you're older
and you come from that like i have seen
a lot of that like i've seen a lot of it
i'm i'm loud i'm opinionated like i will
disagree with a woman and i'm and if i
think they're wrong but if people are
bullying you or shaming you for your
sexual preferences that sounds yeah yeah
yeah and i get a ton of that is someone
that like wears makeup and like has fake
boobs as a comedian but i understand
because that's old there was a scarcity
it was me or you for the longest time it
was like we got to put a woman on the
line up and it was like which fuck it's
gonna be me or you bitch like and i know
what it's like to be jealous i know what
it's like to remember sorry what when
you were when you said something about
just growing up where it's like that's
that like kind of territorial thing
where it's like if we're in a cage
together one of us is going to survive
and i just gave up and was like you're
going to survive
i'm
okay stop pretending to be dead all your
fans are gonna be jerking off uh so stop
looking like such a hot honestly if they
jerk
if you
if you have the instinct to fuck a dead
woman and me playing cosplaying it
allows you to jerk off privately and not
desecrate a corpse
go for it let me ask you
so i want to talk more about i mean the
rough sex thing i guess i just i it's
something i feel the need to talk about
because i think i get this weird guilt
about it i get this weird like oh i'm
not allowed to like this and what if i'm
encouraging this guy
to like because the next girl might not
be into this
you know what i mean like what like the
fact that i even have to worry about
that is crazy and i shouldn't have to
but i will be like it's not on you
it would have trained someone how to be
an attentive lover
yeah it's just i think it's something
that could be really really fun until
it's not there's just such an amazing i
think people are fascinated with sex
because it sounds salacious but i think
that we can't conflict and this is where
i get serious because i met the fucking
victim's family you know what i mean but
like i think it's really important to
just like sorry you can still i didn't
mean to so is he single
are these probably
he's probably still dating in florida
that guy if anyone i'd you know like
yeah maybe you could take him like
physically just killing a woman in
florida is that considered a saintly
thing to do is that considered a kind
thing to get them out of that gym
i by the way to her family
i'm actually not pro florida now though
i not like their whatever nothing
against florida i like go we went to
florida and i was like actually i like
it here and uh i think when you go it's
so beautiful actually in so many ways
you're like oh i feel like they plant
some of these crazy stories just so less
people move here
oh that's a
conspiracy that's me cool
okay i want to know about this all i was
going to say is just that
the only point i want to make is that
rough sex defense is not legit people do
not consent to die of course not there's
rough sex and if you like rough sex and
it gets rougher and then one day you
don't like a fucking waiver before you
have sex and then that's hot that is
actually like if you want if you're like
i want to be that is right
i want this
i'm gonna make you feel safe because you
gotta make men feel safe i just don't
think a killer is going to honor his
waiver
no but if you're the waiver says if
something happens to me you're okay okay
because i'm sorry if you're really if
you're really because in this situation
and this story the guy stayed with the
body for three days like it's not it's
not a rough sex story right right but
they use the references
and they prayed on like the jury just
kind of being like yeah she was a slut
yeah and they denigrated this poor woman
and like you know made her seem like
whatever and they i mean there's so much
someone that likes being denigrated i'm
going to tell you i don't know if they
had sex though the thing is it's like
they they're like they don't even know
if there was a sex act involved
a woman just said interesting
interesting and she died in her in like
a bedroom that wasn't even hers
interesting and then he stayed with the
body for three days and then his
attorney was like
we're gonna say that
you thought she choked on your dick you
don't even know she went down there's no
no he was mung diving whatever don't go
no i can't laugh because i've met her
family sure
i think here's the here's where i can be
helpful on the rough sex thing i'm not
saying like everyone have sex it's like
if that's what you're into totally fine
if your gut tells you like i think
that's what it's taken me the longest
time to grapple with is to go yeah i'm
into this i'm into this i mean well
that's hot like yeah my hand behind my
back totally like it's so fun to like
surrender to this person and then
it goes like just a little further and
you're like i don't like this and then
you're like but i just was into all this
other stuff so now i don't get to say
you do but that's what took me a while
and i think that's the interesting part
consent isn't you can't you can say stop
at any moment
and just because you were in the
handcuffs yesterday doesn't mean you
have to do it again today and then you
can actually never do it again you can
yeah you can be having sex and say i
don't want to have sex anymore or i
don't have it this way or i don't like
it this way or that's not i'm not into
that and like if he's into you not being
into it that's a very big red flag and i
think it took me
there's a difference in terms of like
rough sex being like you want to like
hurt me or this is like this fun like
trust game that is kind of more about
like
me showing my dominance because you're
so dominant in your everyday life and
it's fun to just like and then we go
back
yeah and then
that dynamic is left in the bedroom and
now
you know it's a completely different
thing i'm not like throwing you against
like the kitchen while you're working
you know what i mean like i've been in
situations in relationships whereas like
the rough sex just escalated and it just
it just got when it was like oh this
person becomes like an abusive dynamic
well this person is just going numb and
getting desensitized and needs more and
more to get aroused and i i'm past the
point where this is why you got to bring
in bear claw this is when i bring in my
sex robot bringing it back no i do it to
me first that thing is very expensive
don't
do not hurt that at all uh i cannot
afford to get her arm back on but i
think that it's that the guilt of like
i've already been into these things now
for me to draw the line now i'm like a
handful you know what i mean well then
you're just with the wrong person
totally but i think it's but i think
that that to me is the nuance where it's
like oh now that there's i have to go
with the duct tape because i went with
the rope it's like no you don't yeah and
that's that that and then for uh and if
the guy's not or woman whatever isn't
like cool
that's that's where we're like in a
dicey situation i think
what you're you are not no it's fine i
mean i mean i just think like
you know you just gotta hope
hopefully you are with somebody who
respects your boundaries and how and and
you're changing boundaries and listening
that's what it is you can change your
mind at any time you can leave any
situation whenever you want with no
explanation and that's when it's like oh
i don't have to perfectly articulate and
convince someone that my feeling is
valid or rational i can just have it and
that's all any i need to know so it's
like i have a feeling that i need to
leave why
don't need to tell you i'm leaving just
leave yeah like i don't want to have sex
to you why not don't have to it does not
matter why i'm going to just have smart
feet and i'm just going to leave
in six months i might know how to
articulate it i might never but i'm
that's enough information for me even if
i can't verbalize it so that is
something that i because i've talked
about this before gavin duback or gift
of fear a book i give everybody um every
woman i know uh which is that women uh
most women that were like attacked they
in their post interview uh they always
say i knew something was off about that
guy but like he was doing all the right
things yeah you know so yeah you
reminded me when they if they talk ill
of their ex or like yes yes their past
relationship history because i do think
that like with the psychos
there are patterns of it's like patterns
the abuse and that it's patterned
behavior so um
in episode three of the show of siren
that's what i'm thinking about like he
actually like
he had he had basically
almo tried to kill a woman left her for
dead
because the jury didn't take sexual
assault against women seriously he got a
reduced sentence he got out of prison
and then ended up killing another woman
the way he killed the second woman was
very close to how and then the first
woman in a victim impact statement at
his pearl hearing was like if you let
him out he's going to do that he's going
to kill this woman then the second woman
he i don't want to get too into it but
like you know she had
found out that he was in prison
and she trusted that the system would
never let somebody so dangerous out and
her trust in the system is really
yeah
but if you don't trust the system you're
just going to go to bed every night
being like the system like how do you
then you have to live with the but let
me ask you because this brings me to
something that because my brain just
goes like like you know
this is these are
like psychopaths like i'm sure there's
men that have killed and women that have
killed there's a spectrum there's a
spectrum right but just in talking about
a lot of um
uh did you watch mine hunter david finch
is my david fincher's mind hunter no
it's excellent it's about serial killers
it's ted bundy's in it charles manson
like famous serial killers and their
story and it leans very hard into number
one
it's my mom's fault she didn't love me
enough she didn't let me wear her
pantyhose she didn't like let me wear
hers
it's always the mom's fault like is that
something that you've seen in a like
they usually will go like this guy
couldn't stop killing women what did the
mom do wrong i think it no i talked
about that in miscarriage of justice my
second hour which ended up not getting
you know the pandemic happened so i
wasn't able to tour it but but the there
was a joke about like blaming moms you
know
and uh yeah she just fucked me more i
know i wouldn't be i wouldn't i mean
that like goes for like our larger
societal thing and we fucking hate moms
because it's like married and have to
have a kid from sex like why should you
yeah and i think like our society just
like hates moms and you can see it by
like not having paid leave and by
everything she worked too much she
didn't work enough yeah like she was
always blamed it's like you know she's
like he's a son of a bitch or he's like
a motherfucker you know like i mean
people fucking hate moms and so i think
that like that's part of it but i also
think and i should watch mine hunters
but another thing that i feel like it'll
drive you a little nuts just fyi well
i'm just i'm gonna be bored by serial
killers it's like their stories see
that's the worst thing you could say to
a serial killer see that's what will get
you killed
i you're not special you're not
interested i am bored
like not laughing in a male comedian and
you can't this is that like that all
it's really boring to kill women it's
really easy and boring that's true do
something else maybe don't kill us yeah
that's actually the coolest thing you
have restraint yeah yeah yeah psychopath
so i am involved in this organization
that um uh if we can start linking
uh violence against animals at a young
age
into like a database with the police it
is like the easiest way to figure out if
someone is a like actual neurological
psychopath is interesting kill a cat at
seven years old if they throw a dog into
a bonfire if they throw battery acid on
a cow like it is very easy to predict
who is going to be a psychopath and who
isn't going to be a psychopath but
there's no one like making that link
together like this person threw two cats
off two roofs like let's watch this
motherfucker so i a thousand percent
agree with that and on another taking
that to the other point no one's even
making the link between domestic
violence and mass shootings or domestic
violence
men who hurt women
hurt men too
great
so yeah so it's like animals women
society sure i mean like men who fuck
with animals
will will be violent probably to women
or people in general men who are violent
to women might hurt men sure so it's
like that and i remember when i met with
gloria gloria allred one of my
obsessions in life she is we had laura
wasser on the podcast um as you all
remember uh brilliant lawyer gloria
allred is basically like the
oprah of like lawyer like she was the
first big defenseman that was the tricky
i'm sure
already she's the most famous lawyer
she's very controversial she's probably
like in her 70s now
and was defending like victims of sexual
violence she's the durian
who's that durian is like this
polarizing fruit that smells like
gasoline
but people in asia love it
you can just say honeydew
she's just like the polarizing you know
what i mean like half the world loves
her but even if she's like a monster the
durian of her being
having
like she's still
a gangster because
she gets it done you know what i'm
saying she did it at a time where i very
much feel i'm the glory all right of
comedians you are the glory all right of
communion i do also feel like so gloria
all right she was raped at gunpoint by a
doctor she had an abortion illegally in
a back alley when there weren't and now
she's like this like infamous like ball
buster and i want more people who are
like anti-choice to be like if we make
abortion illegal like that she's like a
superhero and that was her origin story
yes but like if you met her she'd be a
bitch to you and that's okay i'm on her
side i think she's nice to most people i
was a little i came in hot a little bit
like a little kind of trolley but one
thing off camera i'd asked her i'm like
we should have the way that we have like
sex offender registries where you know
who's a sex offender yeah if we did that
for domestic violence like if we were
like if you have a domestic violence
conviction yeah and like it could show
up when you apply to say be a police
officer yeah but a lot of women don't
want to report it obviously because then
when they do it's but and then it's on
your record for the rest of your life
that you're a snitch it's like what am i
going to find out i know there are no
answers but i'm just trying to think
like what are things we could do to make
it harder to like get a gun because it's
harder to like be a politician or have
power or like be a cop like no one's
talking about that yeah is the level of
like domestic violence because a lot of
people don't want those jobs like only
malignant narcissists i feel like want
to be politicians in the first place you
know what i mean like no healthy person
i i think at this point if we just took
domestic violence more seriously and
like help people a little bit like
you're just like but i also think that
that also starts with like you know an
awareness of understanding what sexual
violence even is when you're a woman in
the situation so as someone that has
been in a lot of really
sorry it's not just talking about my
sexual violence no no but it's not just
sexual violence it could also just be
like financial control it doesn't it's
not just sexual 100 so which is why it's
like emotional control during all of the
me too shit when i did get a lot of
nasty dms from people in hollywood that
are like how come you're not talking
more about like times happened because
first of all i think this charity is a
fucking scam and i smell a rat i smell a
rat about this thing number one and
number two
um i yes let's why is it on you though
why can't it be on like men that's what
i'm saying friends with those men sure
what like
but i think for me
um
it was it was like okay i've had my ass
grabbed and a lower hand on my back like
i can handle that i would like to talk
about paying women more so if they're in
abusive relations they can actually
leave or they can actually quit that job
or they can actually take their daughter
or whatever they need to do and also um
there's an amazing organization i stand
with my pac that i work with um also and
they a lot of women do not leave abusive
situations because in shelters you can't
take your dog
or your pet
so this actually and oh my god i have a
horror story about someone who like left
and then they killed her cat
i shouldn't i thought you're gonna say a
dog and i was gonna get sad
um
so i also
i all let's i mean let's be honest i bet
the cat i bet it was i thought it was
neck at night
but you're right that is the thing i
think we
the little things you don't think about
which is just like okay or they're kids
sure people stay for their kids they're
controlled you know like it's but i also
think that when you're in that situation
you have kids and stuff like that it's
so easy to gaslight yourself or be
gaslight into being like it's not that
bad i do think like getting into like a
lot of women
are girls or whatever like sometimes
you're pregnant sometimes you've got
kids like that's why all the abortion
stuff is like so heartbreaking because
it's like
controlling and men and again it's not
physical violence a lot of domestic
violence it's like control and like
they'll control you with money they'll
control you you're just kidding you just
can't
get out can we talk about bill cosby for
a second this is just now that we i we
can all agree he's guilty well it was he
said she said said she said she said she
said she said she said she said she said
she said
we now take a manic break of course from
myself and jenna freedman yapping about
uh
the inevitability of us being murdered
by people that love us
to talk about green chef is a ccof
certified meal kit company green chef
makes eating well easy with plans to fit
every lifestyle whether you're keto
paleo vegan gluten free
or by the way just annoying
they have something for you
i love green chef you guys i really do
green chef has given me too much
confidence in the kitchen i'll be in
there like chocolate potato yes chef to
myself
you know what if jeffrey dahmer had had
green chef a lot of those people might
have lived
or they'd been more fun because by the
way
green chef take knives out of the
equation
this is the best way to reduce serial
killers because green chef does it all
for you does all the cutting and
choosing and everything green chef
offers a range of recipes to suit your
preferences fava beans
even if you like to eat even if you're a
cannibal
green chest pre-proportioned ingredients
mean you'll actually reduce your food
waste by at least 25 compared to grocery
shopping green chef's pre-made and
pre-measured sauces dressings and spices
get you more chef curated flavor in less
time green chef offers 35 nutritious and
flavorful options to choose from every
week featuring premium clean ingredients
that are seasonally
sourced for peak freshness as the first
ever and only keto meal kit on the
market green chef makes sticking to a
carb conscious lifestyle easy go to
greenchef.comwhitney130 and use code
whitney130 to get 130 off plus free
shipping that's like you could get 10 of
these coats for 130
you sure could
again go to
greenchef.comwhitney130 and use code
whitney130 to get 130 off plus free
shipping the number one meal kit for
eating well don't use your knives to cut
up vegetables and cook bring it to our
shows to put us out of our misery throw
them directly at us on stage from all
across the country on january 29th in
durham north carolina we'll be at the
carolina theater on february 3rd
charlotte north carolina can't wait to
see you night
theater february 4th charleston south
carolina will be at the charleston music
hall uh with our band many people when
they see my stand up they're like that's
like
music to my ears like my voice is
basically because you're always talking
in soprano it's basically
musical uh february 5th wilmington
wilmington wilmington delaware what did
delaware i don't know alaska
the grand opera house and if it's in
wilmington you know it's grand
gran you don't even say it's grand if an
opera
if it's in wilmington delaware i mean
that is a rococo opulent opera house we
know and on february 10th cincinnati
titty
theater back to jenna friedman who also
makes me go
what is the logic like have you gotten
the logic of why a man wants to do that
is because number one he's embarrassed i
think he's afraid of powerful women
cosby blocked me on twitter
i think he doesn't like i think he i
think he wants
like adult like he wants bear claw he
wants like a sedentary but why do you
drug is the psychology of of power i
want you to be drunk so i don't have to
worry about your needs and you won't see
me come like you won't see my dick i can
just use your body as a yeah i think
it's just power and control because he
could obviously get anyone he wanted
consensually yeah he could get anyone he
wanted but he wanted to like victimize
yeah i i don't know because i'm not him
but i i would assume when people violate
women like serial predators like that i
think it's about power and control more
than sex or anything else like i think
like that like you know if you're a
billionaire and you're like like a
wealth hoarder and you're like sick fuck
yeah like preying on real humans is like
it's like a flex to gets you off like
it's it's because i'm obsessed with the
psycho like being able i can like and
the lack of accountability you keep
doing it you keep doing it all these all
these other well that's a big thing is
getting away with it it's almost like
shopping the worst part it's a lot of
worst part but it's not the worst part
but a lot of
people around him all his agents but a
lot of the situations that i know like
very a lot of it becomes a gambling
addiction i got away with this so can i
get away with this and it becomes like a
like like shoplifting is about getting
away with it yeah it's about like sad
like women shoplift and like men just
like assault women
it's just like lifeless just spiritless
fear
like men like men versus women
we'll steal lipstick from sephora and
he'll steal your future
your ability to ever have a relationship
and sleep at night and anything besides
like a suit but i uh that is that just
reminds me of benton used to work at
sephora and he said that the way women
shoplift lipstick
i know is they they twist it all the way
to the top and they put it in their
mouth and they walk out with it yeah i
have just had a mask of like uh maria
who played two tarping like monkey cock
she was like eating a lipstick by the
way that wasn't lipstick that was
chocolate right okay good that was
chocolate i feel
better um but hold on i'm obsessed with
being able to talk about psychopaths and
so it's about without like taking it
personally or getting scared like
because i just um they're basic they're
really actually did you see the
interview i did with uh gil volley the
cannibal cop
when was that it was a soft focus
yes and this guy was a police officer in
new york city and he was like plotting
to eat his wife and then his wife was
threatened by him she was like
suspicious that she put spyware in the
computer and caught him and then he used
nypd's software to stalk her and then he
ended up like in prison for thought
crimes and it was like this
controversial controversial case of like
can someone go to prison for what they
think which it actually he went to
prison because he used nypd software to
like stock and like pla he follows me on
twitter he will see this but i'm sorry
really quick he wanted to eat his wife
but no other women he wanted to eat her
friends he was like plotting to eat her
friends and he would like
it he never did anything
how do you what he like put in writing
or he would like me he would talk to men
on message boards and like plot like
different ways to cook women and eat
them sure anyway i interviewed him and
the take or my the way i did it which
still makes me giggle was just being
like you're just like this basic guy
like this guy yeah like everyone does
this like you're totally and that
instead of like elevating him to be this
mythical creature you just kind of like
and there's there's something very funny
about that but i think i mean
were the girls
bigger girls
so i don't know but i don't know what
the women he actually like plotted to
eat look like we did a dating game thing
with him like we did
it's
it's just a weird thing that adult swim
let me do if i'll send you it it was
very funny because we just he was i saw
that he was dating again and he was like
the guy who went to jail he was a
cannibal cop
and so we're like let's do a
self-focusing where we like ambush him
with a dating game but then like at the
last minute we were like we wanted to we
we don't want to just make fun of him
like is there a woman who would date him
so he went on our producers went on some
like um website like like this like
thing where it's like people who are
into blood play and blah blah and we
found this woman who's like into that
shit tender
there you go
that's great
yeah but we put her on the panel and
they connected and whatever it's done
but i don't know why i think i thought
of gil what brought him to my mind of
just like we as attendance we have a
tendency to like glorify these guys but
they are just dudes a hundred percent he
was like a dude who should have been
like a like a stephen king no to me it's
like it's also like a loser because it's
like if you have a lot of friends you
learn like oh i can't do that like if
you're just like
vulnerable women too yeah prey on like
yeah yeah
yeah i understand why you're so scared
because you actively just like kicked
the hornets with these motherfuckers but
like uh but here's the thing i am
obsessed with how psychopaths like
usually when they're in their interviews
after they've killed a woman
they didn't
plan to kill them they just they were
like she kept making noise and i had to
make the noise stop
is that true i have no idea often
they're just trying to solve a problem
and the solving the problem just
happened to be killing a woman really
and a lot of times they're like she just
wouldn't stop screaming so i had to stop
her from screaming like or is that what
they just say i feel like they get off
on freaking people out i feel like the
real psychopaths like get off on like if
you could just if you were like a if you
were
a woman who was a masochist yeah and you
met like a like a psycho and he just
came like it i feel like he would if if
you're not afraid of him it would be
less the kill for him would be less fun
yes but i think that if i kill you it's
like i don't get to rape you i don't get
to have ruined you you know what i mean
and keep you alive it's less sadistic to
actually put someone out of their misery
right you want to keep someone alive and
torture them so but just a lot of them i
don't i don't know if they have the
ability to you know lie very definitely
do you think that they're watching this
thinking like they got it wrong like in
a way that people get like feel like
it's like we're talking about them like
a monolith when there's a whole spectrum
we're talking about them the way guys
talk about women like they feel good
language yeah yeah they don't want to
kill us each of them on their own little
snowy
because he likes you too much like he
didn't want to kill you he just wanted
to stop the noise like yeah and the lies
i tell myself yeah they're like
literally murdering someone where
they're like watching you and they're
like she has it wrong
[Applause]
i got it
but yeah i'm just i am fascinated by it
because i do think that there is a level
of mental illness that is so severe that
and until we like
have a conversation about like this is
something you're born with something
wrong whether it's nature nurture
whatever like inherited mental illness
and social treatment
being abused as a kid is fucking massive
you know like um her people hurt people
that's what i say about psychopaths you
know and like pedophiles and stuff it's
like whatever
made your brain not be able to feel
empathy or get off on watching other
people suffer like it does start there's
ways to know early on you know and then
when it comes to like five women dead in
the woods i'm like i did no one yeah
there's no way someone wasn't like oh
yeah i thought it was weird that he
would hit his dog and kick his you know
what i mean like you were saying before
i sure i'm interrupted but the thing
about you like if tracking people it's
really hard to get if a guy because it
is it is almost never that a man will
like kick the dog and then be like
lovely to the women and children inside
so if you see a dog chained up outside
with no water that never goes anywhere
like so same thing with exotic animals
so people uh think i'm like you know a
little batty because i'm obsessed with
exotic animal trafficking and people uh
privately owning tigers privately owning
elephants anything like that is always
abuse and animal trafficking um goes
hand in hand with sex trafficking it's
always the same people so there's a
bunch of thai girls in a in a van
there's also going to be cheetahs and
sharpies and it's the same it's
entitlement it's controversial all the
same people that's why it's like zoos
any of these sanctuaries
all the same people there are always red
flags except that vegas shooter what
were his
uh country music not a fan of country
music
that's a red flag you know how to appeal
to america i really do i know my demo
i see i don't have the balls to say that
but the south here's what i will say
because i do feel like
there was in there was a the south i
feel like because of the
forget politics for a second like
and i'm going to be very
um i think you should spend more time in
the south because the women in the south
do you know my parents from the south
right now where
oh yeah
what's their address
okay i didn't know that but i spent a
lot of time growing up in the south and
there is i think there's this perception
that that
people in the south are like dumb or i
know there's a lot from the hook worms
it's just the legacy of hookworms it's
just the toxins in the water that they
have a bird well there was a lot of
hookworm there was a big hookworm issue
in the 20s and 30s and that's where the
stereotype of being dumb kind of comes
from but here's what i will say about
southern women as a whole
are
very
a formidable force
and
oh i know a lot of the tricky gun
control stuff comes a lot of women are
like well i want guns to protect myself
i fully get that people like guns and it
stems from feeling powerless they're not
feeling safe and i i completely get that
i don't want to seem like
but it's just if you look at the data
where there are more guns more women
dies yeah yeah fyi yeah but i get that
feeling and like i think a lot of people
who are
not conservative like the comedy of like
the past four years that like you've got
liberal people being like should i go
get a gun you know like there's
something about
people feeling like oh shit maybe i need
a gun but this the data shows where
there are more guns more people die more
women die more than our people i guess
women that are wasted by diet because
they could have been
taken more dicks
and pleased more men tens
it just triggered there are more guns
more tens died because it gets to this
situation where it's like so many more
people that i know are like i want to be
single longer i don't want to get
married before they're i don't want to
like and they're like i want like women
i want to live alone longer and and like
also the research and much like i guess
that you have like a academic on now
like that's or whatever but uh when men
marriage makes men live longer but women
i know you were like waiting for where i
was gonna go and
no that's right yeah because their
testosterone goes down and they have
consistency and they don't have as much
stress and they don't smoke as much they
don't drink as much etc etc but i am
going to work on this like tic tac
series because i have no idea how to do
tic tac i'm not gonna do lazy
cheerleading i'm not dancing like i'm
not doing any of that and i was like how
can i like i know it's a very young
demographic i'm not gonna try to like be
young and like fun even though my shirt
is i'm wearing the worst shirt right now
to say that um but uh i'm gonna do uh
women that live alone tricks if you live
alone because i'm like it's so many
young people on there
like uh when i was single i lived alone
the best thing you can do if you like to
live an apartment alone is get a pair of
like size 12 or 14 shoes shoes
outside your door yeah
hopefully only those people will be
watching this not that not their killers
by the way just now have a new
i was thinking more like you know if
you're choking on something you run into
a table you know like ways to like stop
yourself from choking like if you know
if you're alone and you choke like like
survival sure sure sure run to the
corner of the table or something like to
knock it i don't know yeah like those
kind of just chew longer
yeah
like what are you eating yeah yeah
that's a big one um i used to like dolls
like
like just creepy things yeah create
people yeah creepy people hair on your
dashboard of your car like it's hair
extensions i think that people don't so
lots of old like christmas like ratchet
christmas decorations in like may
there's certain things you can do
that people are like i'm just not gonna
fuck with this person i think that
that's underrated just like the ways
women can scare the little things to
have in your windows i love you too soon
but also just like i love you the
saddest part is you do have it does have
to kind of seem like a man lives in the
house right or the apartment it's like
what
if that's what you want to cut out no i
was what i'm gonna about to say oh shit
no no that's well made a knockout
i was gonna cut it out
that was it
you think amanda knox killed a woman
that just took a shit doesn't do
anything i don't think i'm saying her
the actual murderer took a shit in the
toilet shit yeah if there was a shit
already in the toilet when he went to
see it yeah yeah and he was like there's
a shit in the toilet that must be a man
he was intermittent
and he might have not yeah you know what
i mean so if you leave the shit in the
toilet yes that means a man lives there
that means you're a very horny pretty
girl
do you think that the victim we can't no
i met amanda i was joking
i was thinking i was thinking that you
were saying that meredith curser before
she died should i just take a shit real
quick
you're telling a woman who was
shit in the toilet she didn't flush you
are blaming a victim
indeed
if it was my last shit i would not flash
she didn't know it was i'm saying we
don't she didn't shit and not flush no
he shit he killed her he he killed her
and they got i think he i think he's
shit and then killed him and then killed
her i think she might have been
interrupted no i don't think she was in
her i don't know any speculation
she might have been shitting and he
walked in on she walked in on him
shitting meredith and he got embarrassed
well either way there was shit in the
toilet my point is there's some times
where people have walked in on me on the
toilet and you do shit you are like
like you do overreach
i've definitely done things i don't
remember doing because i was like so
like aggressively try to close the door
yeah you know you could hurt some of my
accidents i almost pushed someone out a
window by accident when i
was in new york and i was taking a shit
out of a toilet to throw out the window
because the toilet wouldn't flush me
came in and i pushed him and he this
sweater fell out onto broadway like that
was around his shoulders his name was
scott i almost killed him i'm sorry
emily and i have both
hooked up with guys in our 20s taking
doo-doos in their new york plumbing
apartments and then it didn't flush and
had to scoop it out and throw it out the
window tampa i've had that with tampons
i didn't throw it out the window but
i've definitely like tried to flush a
tampon which i don't do anymore okay
i gotta wear tampons i use a cup i use
it removable i use my hair i was more of
just like a pipes like i'm more
respectful of pipes yeah yeah but that
wasn't about the diva cup plug i still
she's a really great joke about how like
she at like 75 would just like throw a
tampon down to like except people think
she's so fertile or something like that
whatever she's about the best yes but um
i just didn't want people like plumbers
being like you fucking whore
you do you flush your tampons you
fucking witch die like that is what i
was just afraid that's why i did the
disclaimer of like i you know put my
tampons like i'll wrap them up or find a
toilet not in the back like i do a whole
thing
you know take a fucking bloody tampon
with me rather than you know i
i though you know in the beginning of
your period though when it's like like
tar
yeah
that's i don't put those i don't care
though
those i don't carry tampons with me i
don't carry them with me i just didn't
want people to think no i saw you carry
tampa on the other day you you would
full cardboard you had one on the
cardboard ones yeah i used cardboard
ones yeah you really do really do
no i just they're still organic i know i
know but i just was like i i use a
cardboard applicator isn't that it no
it's it just is a very hillary clinton
tampon
it is um okay i have so many more
questions for you but we're gonna i'm
gonna make you do it again i'm just
going to make you do this again amanda
knox
we i thought we had a good time this
weekend hung out with amanda knox
you two were gonna do a bit together but
you never were able to do it oh sorry
skit
no we weren't gonna do a skit i was like
leave amanda alone she's been thrown off
but this was like 10 years ago oh oh
that i thought you meant this weekend
okay
that would have been really funny but
tasteless yeah no we wanted to a bit
where she walked in and we were
dead on the ground
jesus christ
amanda is innocent that's all i have to
say honestly i was just more worried we
wouldn't get the angles i was like and i
was just like we can't we can't even
pitch this because she's she's been
through so much and she's so cool and
she's
so smart and just you mean you know but
yeah no i i had met her because i was
pitching a bit
in uh you know for my adult swim show
and she she was so
she just took very nicely via email told
me all the reasons it was problematic
and i was like you're right yeah yeah
because i think for her so much of the
not um
being facetious about it it's out of
respect for the yeah meredith yeah
yeah yeah but she did joe rogan recently
and it was it was really amazing because
it's like i mean we did four hours like
we did i had to break into two parts our
interview but i think that there's only
so much a woman can talk to her about to
where
i think guys i kind of need to hear joe
rogan go like yeah you didn't fucking do
it you know what i mean yeah
they listen to us we just sound like um
a charlie brown's teacher or their yeah
their mom yeah they're like yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah no they do they do i'm
just saying they're ambient we're like
at a certain age it's a certain age of
people you know like young guys come up
to me all the time like i listen to your
podcast because i like get all the cheat
codes and like i didn't know that like
you know what i mean can we really
quickly love it yeah or um
my fear is like when someone like takes
a photo with uh with you
and like do you think this is separate
but it's also the same thing when you
said cheat codes it like got my antennas
up
are they
using it to hurt people like are they
using like it's like a photo if they
take a photo with you is it like yeah
they're coming it's coming to my van you
know what i mean like did they do that
because use it as bait
yeah um
if you i see what you mean so you're
like you're their family you're like
they're a feminist weird no it's like
it's like it's like
you know because it's like i love men
and i don't want to like yeah you know
say anything negative but like i feel
like men were doing fine with kidnapping
long before i got it i know but i had a
guy go to my comedy show once and like
bring a date and then afterwards she
totally fucked me because she's like
yeah yeah yeah and i'm like fuck you but
that's not i don't know if that's why
she did i just don't think we have that
i don't think women are so dumb you're
right oh you're right you just schooled
me and you i don't mean to no
i think we have to pick our women weak
or are they strong they're all sorts of
things so everything in between really
quickly to tie it back to true crime i
don't know if you ever saw the keeper
the keepers on netflix it was about the
do you see that it was the keeper or
keepers the keepers there was this
moment where the nun
who's murdered
the killer like is this real yeah he had
her he got her he did he took her vagina
i didn't know like how what the incision
is to get the full scooper
but not like a melon but like
it's picturing but like no ice cream one
not a melon ball i'm sorry excuse me you
miss my society you and your melons and
your chinese fruits like wow
i mean no wonder you think about women's
bodies being just as when you eat melons
you just think of dead women
but whatever so maybe like a
gelato no
no it was like you know those things
that cut apples for you
like you just
you know it's probably one of those i
was well whatever it was anyway yeah he
took the joke it's definitely a shark
tank thing
whatever it is
yes um
anyway he um neither of us cooks
you during the pantheon that's what's
gonna say like that whatever but he uh
but um
there's just like this moment in this
whole nine
nine episode documentary where they're
just like and then he took her vagina
and it was in tin foil and he threw it
on the table and then that they never
talked about it again
it was like one line in nine episodes
and it was just like this
bomb and and and that's all i can ever
think about it was just like this
it's important vagina he scooped it out
with like a i still think it's like that
because it was probably what they cut
the um
i mean there's there's a lot of things
if you sit in church long enough you're
like i i could
definitely sever vagina with that you
get so bored after you know what i mean
what i don't have anything else
so what why did the person want to do
this it wasn't i don't know anything i
think it could have been its own nine
episode sure
sure but it was just like the keepers
and they they this guy killed a bunch of
others
i didn't know the vagina like separated
from the body i just thought it was like
it doesn't it doesn't you have to
look i i i think i think he separated it
no i know but it's like if you it wasn't
like your anal sphincter coming nobody's
like
i picture like if you're gonna
i think it was just her clip i think
they should have said clit okay because
i think i know where you're getting hung
up you're getting
labia it's not like mr potato head he
just like pulled the vagina out and it
was like fully like a plastic
sometimes they prolapse but i think that
whoever made this movie was obviously a
man and they don't know the difference
between a vagina and a clitoris and they
just also know about like the whole
imagine wow you know that in something
but hold on you think about it you make
tv shows really so you wouldn't say
through her clitoris on the table
so they were like it's let's just call
the vagina you know how many meetings
they had about this
they settled on vagina because they
thought it'd be the least confusing and
here you are
[Music]
interesting they had so many meetings
like they're like technically it was
just her like lips and a clit and like
maybe some
like like a smattering of they don't
yeah i think that the forensics people
were like we don't even know what this
is
they couldn't die
they're like is this
i think what did
the forensics were men and the vagina is
just like where does the vagina stop and
the rest of the woman begin
your sex doll people would know because
it could have been her whole body that's
just a vagina as far as i'm concerned
when you say vagina what part do you
what vagina should be is the inside
where the baby would be like that well
that's the uterus technically right yeah
like what what it like the vagina it
doesn't start to like we don't want to
comics we like don't get to talk about
vaginas as much on
really how do you think i built this
house
but i do the vagina doesn't start till
pretty deep in
like it's the clitoris it's the hood
it's a urethra urethra and the vagina
like there's a lot of the vaginas
this isn't really embarrassing the
vagina is like the internal into it but
then you get to uterus but vagina's like
kind of
like the passageway is it like it is
like the throat to your mouth it's like
the tunnel he's he has two kids
a man that has had two child births
knows way more than a woman
yeah that's what it is he knows more
he's like bitches but yeah and yeah
i think i think what happened is they
these two fucking cunts don't know
i mean i don't even know
but i do know wait what's the ta oh
what's the okay the clitoris is the very
very top
then the critters like extends inside
the clitoris could be like as big as a
dick it's like it's all the nerve
there's like it's not just the tip the
tip is just what is that and then inside
the g-spot's in there somewhere so i
hear yeah so yeah yeah
uh well i'm very i'm looking forward to
watching that so that i can corroborate
and see
the keeper but did she die
or he just cut her pussy off okay i'm
just curious
this is a dad you could survive having
just the like if it was just your clit
you know
it would no no no it was this there's
people that do that the woman i don't
even know if they ever found the ball i
don't know what happened but there's
just this one moment in this like nine
episode nine hours of content there was
just this one moment where they're like
and then they threw the vagina on the
table like they threw this thing on the
table country board yeah and it was like
covered in like i don't me if there was
no timber cubes it was a nun if there
was no tin foil in the documentary then
i don't know where that came from where
i just picture i picture like a left
like some like like thanksgiving
leftovers sure sure yeah that's just
like a yam or like a human heart even
yeah yeah he went to the kitchen and got
some tinfoil and like respectfully to
preserve it a lot of these guys put
stuff in freezers for later but it was
like in making of a murderer where was
like 10 episodes
and they're like
the keepers i know but i'm talking about
megan murder there's one line where
they're like and he threw a cat in the
fireplace
oh and you're like whoa whoa whoa
wait wait we have our we got it
okay yes
i know we have to go but ken kratz do
you know who he is nope he was a
prosecutor making a murder i talked to
him i sat down there's a whole story
about this ken kratz said though at one
point there's so much about ken kratz i
have to tell you off camera but at one
point he said that stephen avery threw
the cat into the fire cat left out of
the fire threw him back in
guilty
cut and we got our show
the end special thanks like it's it's
over but that also i i do want you to
watch the staircase
uh because next time this is your
homework for next time you're on because
i think you should talk to the lawyer
that represented him
he's so fucking charming he's so
interesting he
thought like he was even like i don't
know if this guy's like i
this guy should be guilty by all counts
but i don't think he is he's like i
would not ruin my career defending this
guy like the lawyer is kind of the star
of it
and he's so charismatic and he's so
smart and he's like
he's trying to
find the guy he's defending guilty like
he's trying to he's not like i know he's
guilty but i'm just gonna i know i can
manipulate people to think he's not he's
like
i just still don't think he is like it's
it you believe him it's it's a it's a
and he quit a couple times because he
was just like i don't know
it's just like
you even if you're not guilty you just
seem too guilty like i can't help you
dude it's just like even if these are
all coincidences it's just like
too stacked okay like it's too freak you
know like it's it's worth watching okay
because i really just want to know you
think about it because i know that
you'll be right okay and i spent a lot
of time fighting at parties about this
yeah because then you'll get to like
really focus on what i don't want to be
doing the armchair thing i try not to be
like
you start focusing on the real dangers
to women owls
i just want you to keep your eye on the
ball and realize what's really coming
for you especially if your parents live
in the south um they dive on people no i
know my special bonds my sister had a
hawk or like a crow it wasn't a hawk of
the crow and i like got the same crow
got her twice and the crows you know
they recognize faces yeah and they hold
grudges for four years uh yeah they so
they so they did exactly what avery did
with the cat they saw her didn't get her
and came back for her i think she was
ptsd from like twice that same crowd no
but they recognized faces they knew it
was her and they tried again
she was it was the same day she was she
was like just to be clear
they wanted her yeah no
no no no i it's a funny
she was like working on like it wasn't
just anyone they weren't like i'll try
this one and then she was like boots on
and they like had clink she was like
she's i don't want to get into my sister
that's all okay but she was like working
at this like real estate investment
banking company and like looking to like
buy a building and the crows were like
dude 100 also you know you'll like this
and i've mentioned this on almost every
podcast but since if you're listening
this you're going to like this because
you'll probably get a bunch of people
listening to this that don't normally
listen because they're murder murder
buffs um and researchers um that
vultures help solve crimes because i
know you i know you'll love this i talk
about the podcast all the time and
nobody is interested except you and uh
about because vultures they because
they're scavengers and they only rely on
something that's already dead that's
what that means is that they uh will
only fly somewhere if it's the optimal
nutrition of the flesh so if it's their
brain so if there's a body in the woods
and then there's
vulture feathers 40 feet away it means
it was a gunshot wound because they
moved they flew to the brain
wow it's super cool there's a ted talk
on it this like woman this like texas
woman in like cowboy boots like talking
about how she like takes vultures in the
woods to solve crimes it's like i'm
obsessed i want to like be her assistant
that's cool
okay i end these very awkwardly it's
great uh indefensible now i just went on
amazon and got it great because i
couldn't i couldn't i don't get paid
trying to find it was like trying to
solve a murderer i know i know so i just
go to amazon i just got on amazon it was
so easy to watch but i know it's also on
sundance tv which i'm sure you guys know
how to find that amc plus is where it's
streaming okay sometimes air is on
sundance but amazon i think is where
most people would get it yes and then um
hopefully the ted bunny thing is still
on youtube oh yeah and jenna just look
up jenna's stand up uh i listened i
re-listened on spotify this morning it
was so i've not listened to stand-up on
spotify before like i was looking to see
that you if you had been on another
podcast and then
uh i really don't do them a lot i know
this is a big deal
i mean you're gonna tell us to not air
it i i feel this coming i think
everything
i think it's fine yeah i don't know i
think so too you can listen back to it
but i promise you it's it's fine yeah it
might it might you just did a thing like
it won't kill your career
because i thought of a joke like that i
felt like i couldn't say
oh that's what we do if a guy tries to
murder me i'm just like i'm gonna make
like i'm like ah like that i think is
how you get out of it out of a mass
shooting you go with it you play dead
for mass shooting really yeah
and you'd rub someone else's blood on
you if they're splitting oh wow that's
really you can't let them see you
no i think they're like never mind dude
you're let's work together you're
fucking you're stupid you start munging
and the shooter is like you know what
you guys are back dude
he's just gonna blow his brains out
that's some fucking grossest shit
if you're just like i start rubbing your
body onto one of the recently dead
corpses he's like dude uh
i'm gonna just slowly walks out of the
room
turns himself in he's like the police
oh no just kills himself
but yeah i did i used to have rape jokes
when i first first started that i know
are gonna get me in trouble but i used
to say like uh i'm i i feel very
confident that i'm never gonna get raped
because i just won't say no
like just how like if someone starts
raping you if you're like you know come
on i want it like will that help
i honestly think i don't know anything
obviously but like you know the um
golden state killer like i was such a
little like
you know like i feel like if a woman was
like like now this direction like this
move yeah just got a window into like
mine
not this way
do you feel like there's something like
they're so afraid and emasculated that
if you try to take control but i'm not i
don't want
yeah but last thing okay and i didn't do
this in the show this weekend because i
do this whole thing about 23andme and i
forgot about the joke where people don't
want their data on 23andme but it is
solving crimes yeah it is even crazy
they literally the niece of the golden
state killer right pat and oswalt's wife
was doing a whole story on this and he
wrote i mean the book is out and i think
and there might be a documentary too but
how the golden state killer killed all
these women he's been just only living
in san francisco and his niece does a
23andme test it goes into the police
database they fucking find this guy like
taking out the trash put him in jail and
um uh and people like i don't want to go
on 23andme because like what if they
have my data it's like you'd rather just
like know serial killers are walking
around then give your email yeah out
yeah meanwhile your phone's on you i
mean like you your joke was really great
about it like yeah i'm so like working
on that area but it is fascinating to me
that like they're just serial killers
that they're just like oh someone was
like i want to know if i'm norwegian and
then like a serial killer goes to jail
but if your dad or uncle like really
doesn't want you to do it
but that's the that's the thing if you
bring it up you know what if you bring
it up it bring up 23 on christmas and if
someone's like oh no you know if they
were going to take your data yeah you
really shouldn't do that feel like if
they're taking our data they're not
doing a good job because all these mass
shooters have so many red flags on the
internet and nobody's shocking them the
government's listening to everyone
except the people that are like hey
alexa how do i buy a gun and shoot up a
school and they're like i'm like aren't
they listening and they're listening i
thought they were listening i thought
they were recording and listening yeah
yeah just not the people googling
literally and they're like his google
search was like how do i stream full
page had like a gun and it was like
tomorrow no
the government's spying on us
not hard enough not hard enough oh my
god okay i love you this is very this is
very exciting it was very fun for me
i end these very awkwardly don't write
elephants jennafriedman.com
i never update it but if you want to go
there sure and you're she's touring uh a
bit i'll be touring a little bit watch
indefensible uh hilarious and insightful
at the same time that never happens and
do red elephants we love
[Music]
four four you
[Applause]
you